hi there steve here
today i'm going to talk about language
learning
as a form of exploration and discovery
because that's what it is for me and
that's what motivates me to learn
languages
and i'm going to do this on today which
is uh christmas day
it doesn't matter what religion you are
i think it's
most widely known as uh christmas day
because
according to the christian religion this
was the day when jesus christ
was born
now we don't know when jesus christ was
born
uh it is also true that the 25th of
december or thereabouts
has been a very common sort of day of
feasting or festival or ceremony in all
kinds of cultures and traditions
from the ancient iranians to
syriac religion which believed in some
kind of a sun god
to
the romans who celebrated saturnalia
which was some kind of a celebration of
the end of the
sowing season you know in agriculture
and great feasting took place
and not to mention the
northern europeans who
and that's where we get the christmas
tree from and they lit bonfires to
encourage the sun to come back because
it was the shortest day of the year or
around the shortest day of the year sort
of a winter solstice
festival even in japan this amaterasu
coming out of the cave museum and the
mayans there's all kinds of examples of
why this
is a time of the year when people
celebrate and encourage the sun to come
back and
this kind of thing
now
i was recently with my wife
in
jerusalem
and uh this was part of a trip that
included greece
and jordan
and for me
exploring these languages greek
uh hebrew which i
just dabbled in
enough to me to be able to make out some
of the
letters when i see them written
somewhere
i'll get back to it and of course arabic
which i am now committing myself to
learning
it's part of a desire to discover more
about that part of the world it's
interesting to think
that you know the bible uh of course
there's a hebrew bible
but much of the certainly the new
testament was written in greek
um
in
you know the
constantine the emperor constantine made
christianity the official religion of
the roman empire which contributed to
its dramatic growth it's now the largest
religion in the world
uh as a result of constantine's decision
and he was he apparently spoke latin and
didn't speak greek that well although
his mother was greek
but in uh constantinople and that part
of the um
the roman empire a lot of people this be
greek maybe greek was certainly was more
common
than latin although educated romans uh
spoke greek
because it was considered the language
of of sort of culture and so forth and
and the local people spoke various
semitic languages
aramaic or phoenician i don't know
um
and that those ancient languages which
which really again i don't know all of
this they they don't quite know the the
language of ancient sumer just what kind
of a language it was like
it seems to be an isolated language
although some rabid nationalists try to
claim it as the
ancestor of their own language in
different language groups uh but soon
thereafter this semitic language the
sumerian or excuse me acadian or acadian
took over and this is also the ancestor
of hebrew and aramaic and and arabic and
so forth and so on so so the study of
arabic today for me and greek and if i
ever get into hebrew but much much
smaller number of speakers is a form of
discovering a little bit about
that part of the world
uh the history that preceded
uh
islam and then since islam and a lot of
the culture
that developed after
and i'm curious to understand you know
what are the different influences that
led to the wonderful examples of arabic
culture that are on display for example
that i visited in spain in southern
spain so these are all kinds of things
that i want to explore and i want to
explore
going further east iranian and
eventually the languages of india and so
forth and so on
but
so languages are a form of exploration
uh of discovery
learning about different people
but uh the other thing of course about
christmas day is that it is for many
christians a religious day
and the message is one of peace
peace humility
helping those less fortunate than you
turning the other cheek forgiveness
tolerance a lot of qualities
that seem to be absent
today in politics
absent today
in the way different religious
groups
interact
it's almost as if religion has become
more a matter of identity
my group is better than your group
and this leads to violence and
intolerance and we do see this in the
middle east
and so i guess the message
other today other than to encourage
people to learn languages as a means of
discovering more about
human history human beings people who
share the planet with us while we are on
this planet
other than that positive i want to
inject some positive motivation if
possible i mean people are all motivated
differently
in favor of language learning
but also
to suggest that
hopefully we can get back to the
fundamental
message of most religions and
most religions
you know while they have a sense of
identity there and symbolism and
ceremonies at the core of most religions
are
a set of fairly universal values and it
seems that
maybe it's always been there but there
seems to be an element of nastiness and
intolerance that has
has come to dominate
uh relationships between different
national groups religions and so forth
and so on so
hopefully today is a day that we think
what might be possible if people
actually followed the moral teachings of
their religions
and i should add those people who don't
believe in religions such as me
okay i have no opinion on the existence
or non-existence of of a god i simply
don't know
but
i guide my self in terms of moral values
and how to behave
based on what i think
how i think i would like to be treated
by others
and i think that basic
concept exists in all religions and so
if we can be
perhaps guided more by the old golden
rule
things might improve but i don't hold
out any hope and so i continue learning
my languages bye for now
[Music]
you